navigating the landscape of healthcare
benefit options for veterans and
Medicare can be daunting well Humana the
sponsors of this next segment are here
to help joining us now is Kevin Greene a
sales director with Humana welcome to
the show my friend hey thanks for having
me first off you are a very stylish man
I think we're dressed exactly the same
today yeah we are on point I'm a big fan
of yours so I'm a big fan of yours Kevin
uh let's talk about this give us a quick
overview of the Medicare plan options
yeah so we call it the ABCs of Medicare
so there's Medicare part A that's your
hospital Insurance most people don't pay
for that then you have Medicare Part B
most people pay a monthly premium that's
your doctor co-pays your Specialists
things of that nature then you have
where Humana comes in that's your
Medicare Part C so that's really a Step
Beyond original Medicare we like to
think it's more affordable and gives you
additional options including
prescription drug coverage things of
that Nation now we tie in with with
veterans if they're eligible for VA
benefits do the benefits in Medicare do
they overlap the two of them how does
that work it's a great question we get
that all the time time so veterans that
have VA benefits or access to the VA
actually recommends that they do join
original Medicare first and foremost
okay to access all their options and
then Medicare Advantage or forms of
Medicare coverage they can supplement
the VA coverage so it gives them more
access to care outside of the VA to see
doctors Specialists and can provide
additional benefits that they may not
have access to with the VA well that's
we have a next question I think you
might have answered it but what are some
of the things that Medicare will cover
that their VA benefits will not cover
lots of things it could start with
prescription drug coverage it may be
over-the-counter items dental coverage
Vision even transportation to and fro to
to your uh to your providers and it also
gives you access to that additional
opinion outside of the VA okay Tricare
and I had to write it down Champion
tracker how does it all tie into
everything people watching they
understand what I'm talking about how
does it all tie into everything well
that's another uh it's another form of
coverage that's offered through Veterans
that are retired and they all also
should they should take a look at what
their options are they should talk to
someone from Humana Medicare a licensed
Medicare representative because they may
not have access to all of their needs in
addition to the original Medicare okay
what are some of the benefits Beyond
Medicare
uh there's the transportation there's
reduced co-pays and coinsurances there's
access to care first and foremost so
here specifically in Nevada oftentimes
with the VA it gets backed up it's hard
to get into a doctor when you need to so
it's nice to have that in your back
pocket to say hey I've got options yeah
and then this just gives you more
options more options and someone's
watching right now they've got questions
and you've got the answers how do they
get in touch with you humana.com is the
first is the best way to do it and I'd
recommend that they do it soon because
right now is your annual enrollment
period it runs only until December 7th
so we have to make our decisions coming
up soon it's coming up next week so we
gotta you know give us a call yeah go
online it's a
702-837-4462 is our local office I love
it Kevin thank you so much for joining
us again you're a very sharp dressed man
I love you very stylish again there's
the number on the screen Humana
702-837-4462 or visit humana.com Las
Vegas now we'll be right back